hi everybody I'm Laura Ingram this is
the Ingram angle from Washington now for
those of you who are new to the angle at
7 pm Eastern thank you for watching
tonight and for everyone else who
watched at 10 p.m you're going to like
us even better earlier so this is my
these are my rules okay we're gonna keep
learning keep laughing I'm going to keep
winning together and it's a great
privilege to be here every night but now
where things stand that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now it seems to me that the Democrats
know they're in one big old hole now
first having Joe Biden as their nominee
it's very risky and at the same time not
having them as their nominee maybe even
riskier
now how did this happen well during the
2020 campaign when everyone in the Press
already knew Biden was failing well they
propped them up in a full weekend at
Biden style production
they and the DNC knew then what they
know now they could Market him though it
was kind of an older and more stable
than the new far-left Democrats and they
would reassure the seniors and
minorities and independents
but now what
he's only gotten worse and America knows
it and now the country and the party is
stuck with someone who literally
everyone knows is a figurehead president
Joe's not calling the shots on any major
question other than maybe whether he'll
have Jello or pudding for dessert and
look let's be honest Dr Jill probably
makes those decisions for him
now with his cat naps and his regular
stumbles we're dealing with weekend at
Biden's returns
now trying to bring him back to
political life the media they're blaming
everyone but themselves for the vine
they're in
yes he's 80. you need to be there for
him and you need to make a pathway you
can't have these video images of the
president tripping or the president like
going the wrong way
well sometimes they try to pretend that
he's actually serving as president even
when they know he's not
well yeah he keeps a very rigorous
schedule we know that of course it would
be easy for the Democrats to get rid of
Biden but they're stuck with him because
all of their potential plan B's are
non-starters
Biden's a figurehead but even Biden
without a brain he's less terrifying
than Kamala with half of one
culture is it it is a reflection of our
moment and our time right and and and
present culture is the way we express
how we're feeling about the moment
and
and we should always find times to
express how we feel about the moment
that is a reflection of Joy because
every you know
it comes in the morning
well speaking of Joy it won't be found
in that Gavin Newsom option either
California used to be known as the
Golden State until left-wing politics
hit it's now the go somewhere else state
now more than 40 percent of Californians
are considering moving and one-third
blame liberal policies
but the governor's not worried that
people are voting with their feet this
is the first time in the history of the
state that you've lost population you
didn't acknowledge per capita more
Floridians coming back to California and
Californians going to Florida this was
anomalous 18 states saw decline I love
this state don't count us out
oh no that spin is not going to fly and
neither will the regime's attempts to
spin the Biden economy we're very uh
happy to see some breathing room for
American households our wage growth is
moderating and inflation is uh subsiding
so I think we're in a good path on the
United States
now even Twitter had to correct Biden's
latest economic brag he claims real
wages are higher for the average
American worker than they were before
the pandemic it's not true real wages
adjusted for inflation we're at
11.15 now those real wages are at 1105.
well the bottom line is Republicans have
a huge Edge it's awesome in 2024 if they
wish to exploit it
but it's not about drag queens story
hours or Trans radicalism in the schools
as important as those issues are and
they are important
but it's about securing the Border but
mostly about the economy because that's
Biden's biggest Achilles heel here's the
Dilemma for the white house so they
clearly need to do a better sales job
especially in talking about things like
the strong job market the fact that
inflation what the White House can do is
one is hope that things continue to get
slightly better and then you've got to
basically explain explain and explain
essentially educate
oh we need to educate and people can't
look at their own bank statements
Richard okay
well at least Biden has an MSNBC you
know panel to augment is com's team
that's good
but what about the Republicans well
Kevin McCarthy he's surprising a lot of
people who doubted him as a speaker
I will not put an Omnibus on the floor
of the house we should do our work we
should do our job and I'm thankful that
you're here in Statuary Hall continuing
to see that this is the people's house
we keep it open to the public members
are now back to have to actually work in
Congress they can't stay home
now if Pelosi had her way the capital
would still be surrounded by razor wire
close to the icky public and would be
well on our way to packing the court
House Republicans are doing their job on
this defense authorization act by trying
to scrub it of all this non-defense
related stuff like paid travel for
abortions how does that make us a better
fighting force
and as far as the presidential race is
concerned no one seems close right now
and the Republican side no one seems
close right now to catching Donald Trump
he's dominating he's dominating in the
polls and he's dominating in fundraising
now people ask me all the time Laura
could that change maybe but over the
weekend Mike Pence and Tim Scott got a
taste of what the GOP base thinks of the
American Munitions drain right now in
Ukraine
now let's just put it this way
the electorate and Raytheon don't have
the same interest in a prolonged war in
Ukraine especially while our border is
open to the South
and whose trend lines would you rather
have with Hispanic voters our fastest
growing demographic of course the
Republicans of the Democrats well
Hispanic support for Democrats slid from
72 percent in 2018 to 60 in 2022.
and obviously DeSantis he showed massive
appeal in his state with Hispanic voters
even in traditionally dominated counties
like Miami-Dade impressive stuff
all right here's the bottom line with my
creaky voice
if you live in a part of America that's
governed by Republicans
you have really good reasons to be
optimistic because your businesses are
growing your schools are most likely not
controlled by radicals
and you're not getting hammered with
unnecessary taxes
but
if you live in California or you live in
New York or Illinois or any place
governed by the radical left you not
only have to deal with a failing Biden
Administration you have to watch your
state grow more and more Fringe radical
at the same time and less competitive
now in 2024 the Republican Party
and I must say this a lot so you might
get tired of it but you know it it
matters some say it a lot
this has to be a no State Left Behind
strategy no Urban America left behind
and no American state left behind that
means all 50 states
because people want to be happy again
everywhere in the United States
including in the blue states where a lot
of them are miserable
so conservatives have the answers now we
just need to get the votes
I made it through and that's the angle
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else